Thanks for clarifying the Mercola article from today is they write these articles not for specific types of disease like cancer drives who does I would agree
So it's just like with anything you just got to be careful of the weighty everything with you. I mean, I think everybody's different first of all and I think there's some people that would do great on a low fat diet like that for a period of time.
And I think there's a lot of people that do great on NAD supplements. I'll tell you I can tell you half a dozen people that reacted horribly to NAD supplements not cancer patients.
That got pal heart computations and all sorts of problems. So everybody's different. That's the thing to remember. So we got to be careful not to speak dog manically in anything that we do.
Or reading health things. There's a lot of information out there. And I have people that send me Instagram videos and Facebook videos of people that are quote unquote at your paths or natural functional medicine doctors that make claims that are just that are just at just are wrong for everybody.
And some are right, but they're not right for cancer patients or some are right, but they're not right for everybody, but they use such dogmatic language.
Okay, somebody, somebody made a video like is copper bad for you. That's nonsense. And he went off on this whole thing about copper is good for you. And we need copper, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. But he's completely wrong. You know, copper toxicity is a huge issue.
Since we put copper pipes in our homes, since we, you know, for many centuries use copper pans for cooking copper toxicity is very common.
And it can be a cause for cancer because it leads to zinc deficiency or we should say a relative zinc deficiency.
A lot of people have ill health because they have a copper overload. And that is an issue. So some people just don't know what they're talking about. And some people are do know what they're talking about that doesn't relate to cancer and some people do what they're talking about, but then they make it so dogmatic like everybody should do this, which standards are not true. Not everybody should do anything. So very few things. So
just be be aware of those things.